what's up guys it's Sean McGinnes and
Kevin Van Horn here at e3 2014 and Kevin
you've just checked out a bit of dying
light I did and tell me however so dying
light is sort of like if it's truly if
Dead Island and Assassin's Creed had a
baby okay
that's kind of what dying light is
except it's in first person so the I saw
two stages when I played the demo the
first was you know it's at the very
beginning of the game you open a door
and you get to take in the city for the
first time and it looks quite beautiful
and and but then you realize that it's
swarming with the undead right of course
and you you get like it at first you
don't get a whole lot of tools your best
bet is to actually simply avoid them and
the best way to do that is possibly to
stay to the rooftops and so it's really
easy to sort of get around in the in the
world by by just climbing up on ruse you
just use a bumper and you can sprint
your way and climb up on top of things
okay it had a little bit of a thief feel
even from the most recent thief and then
the second in the second part of the
demo I actually got a chance to get some
better weapons so at first I only had
like a baseball bat but after a while I
had I was able to get some weapons and
then I also had some some improvements
you get to upgrade your skills and
whatnot
so at that point I was able to just
start bashing some zombies up and
actually you know I think Dead Island
feels pretty clumsy all in all when it
comes to the combat Dead Island is a
little kind of jerky and clumsy and this
feels a lot better
oh there's actually a sense of the bat
hitting you know hitting your your
victim and you know when you climb it
actually feels pretty good it actually
feels like you're climbing that I mean
the first-person perspective when you're
moving around like that how how does it
feel you get nauseous does it sort of
like find ways to alleviate that it's
not going so fast as like say Mirror's
Edge or something like that and you're
not really seeing this bit like the
stuff I did it's not like I was running
on walls at that point I was just
climbing and running in
means some more so you know and it's any
you know the animations are slow enough
again it's not like Mirror's Edge where
I'm I'm really why than agile you know
it's I really did feel like I had some
weight and all in all it felt pretty
good yeah I was I was very happy with
the sense of power with the weapons the
the technology looks much improved over
over Dead Island so overall I was pretty
impressed that it was not it was not
nearly as clumsy as I expected and I've
you know my apologies in advance to the
fine people at Tech land rights but it
was not as clumsy as I expected it to be
and that made me happy well that's good
news
so a bit of a positive take away from
dying light yeah I had a good time with
it all right cool thank you very much
Kevin my pleasure and that was Kevin Van
Horn's take on dying light here at e3
2014 make sure to stay tuned again spot
calm for even more coverage
you